le cortège emmenant les victimes et les
enfants rescapé de l'avalanche
meurtrière devrait regagner la région
parisienne dans la soirée le chagrin et
la dignité des familles l'enquète sur
les responsabilités devrait déterminer
s'il ya eu véritablement imprudence
l'avalanche aurait été déclenchée par le
passage des randonneurs
et puis jacques chirac à bombay pour
conquérir le marché indien en compagnie
des grands patrons français dans ce
journal également phénomène médical
presque unique dans l'histoire à tour
d'une jeune femme met au monde le même
jour deux bébés ont su à trois semaines
d'écart enfin pour le début de sa
tournée avant bercy patricia kaas c'est
l'habitude de ce journal en duplex de
valence où elle se produit si madame
monsieur bonsoir en fin d'après midi un
cortège d'une dizaine de fourgons
mortuaires suivi par les autocars
transportant les familles des victimes
ainsi que les enfants qui étaient
hospitalisées à quitter la région d or
pour rejoindre l'aéroport de marseille
l'avion qui les emmènent devrait dans
les heures qui viennent d'atterrir à
villacoublay nous y reviendrons dans le
cours de ce journal mais d'abord le
chagrin et le recueillement des familles
reportage à cardoze vincent deux ombres
9 défunt leurs parents un long cortège
de douleurs quitte le centre hospitalier
dans bras il est 16h15 soit un peu plus
de 26 heures après une mortelle
randonnée les victimes et quelques
rescapés notamment les blessés légers
sont accompagnés de leurs parents tout
au long de la journée
ceux là ont pu se recueillir dans une
chapelle ardente où un office religieux
a été célébré
je m'attendais à plus de défendre roman
de tous certainement que la douleur de
leur douleur est extrêmement profonde
mais là
la façon dont ils l'ont manifesté de
façon discrète et dignes et courageuses
je crois de être soulignée hommes
d'église venu apporter les condoléances
de monseigneur lustiger di falco hommes
politiques venus témoigner dans la
dignité d'un sentiment partagé
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire qu'il faut
prier pour ceux qui le veulent qu'ils le
savent
beaucoup ont prié qu'il faut pleurer
beaucoup ont pleuré tous ont pleuré nous
aussi
faut se taire faut hurler pour que la
nation la france dise combien est
injuste et scandaleuse la mort des fils
et des filles de france dans la fleur de
leur jeunesse peut-être encore quelques
témoignages avec ses affaires
rassemblées ici dernier souvenir pour
les familles des disparus
les blessés eux ont bénéficié d'un
soutien psy chic particulier nécessaire
après ce qu'ils ont vécu l'accident
lui-même les traumatismes et c'est
surtout d'avoir vu leurs camarades
puisque euros moment les secours sont
arrivés aux mamans on a dû commencer à
ramasser les blessés
c'est sûr que les enfants conscients et
était pas très loin des enfants morts en
fin de journée
c'est le maire de la commune d'où sont
originaires les adolescents qui
souhaitent prendre la parole et se faire
l'avocat des familles le moniteur de ski
jusqu'au mini ce chacun doit s'efforcer
de trouver les moyens de faire que ces
accidents qui se passe trop souvent on
ne se passe plus il ya certainement des
moyens
et puis peu à peu le cortège de douleur
s'était éteint en tous les cas devant
les caméras car pour eux pour ces
familles la montagne ou la fatalité
les aura touché à tout jamais alors que
les familles avaient donc rejoint tôt ce
matin en brun une chapelle ardente la
solidarité s'organisait à montigny le
bretonneux tout faire pour aider ou
soulager la ville en deuil aujourd'hui
drapeaux en berne et les élèves du
collège écrasée de chagrin allant ni
roux relire le nom des victimes ou des
rescapés affiché devant leur
établissement tir et kurt et frédéric
bonnet montigny le bretonneux s'est
drapée de noir toute la ville porte le
deuil les spectacles et manifestations
publiques ont toutes été reporté
des personnes par centaines ont tenu à
se recueillir à manifester leur
solidarité
beaucoup beaucoup de fleurs et le besoin
pour tous d'être ensemble
les élèves les parents des camarades de
classe ne pouvait se décrocher de la
liste des collégiens victimes de
l'avalanche
à l'intérieur les médecins les plus
choqués l'intérieur ils disent rien il
ya des chants des prières en chapelet
c'est un silence
c'est pesant vous votre sentiment
aujourd'hui c'est un sentiment de
recueillement où déjà un sentiment de
colère de colère pourquoi on sait pas
encore inquiète sans porter d'accusation
mais c'est pour l'instant on connait
rien n'était pas un faux attendre des
enquêteurs dans l'après-midi la plus
grande salle de sports de la ville a été
réquisitionné pour abriter la chapelle
ardente
demain les habitants de montigny
pourront venir s'y recueillir
dès 10 heures des médecins psychologues
reviendront lundi et poulets les
professeurs pour la reprise des cours et
nous rejoignant maintenant direct tiré
kurt et vous êtes à montigny le
bretonneux depuis hier soir la
solidarité a joué on l'a vu et la ville
attend du nord à l'autre le retour des
rescapés et des victimes
oui béatrice vous pouvez l'imaginer les
parents des victimes ont vécu
aujourd'hui un véritable chemin de croix
ils sont partis devant ce collège de
saint françois d'assise à 6h ce matin
vers direction aix en provence puis
embrun ils sont repartis donc d'embrun
vers 16h direction aix en provence ils
ont repris l'avion les avions les deux
avions l'un transportant donc les corps
ainsi qu'un second transportant donc les
victimes et les parents des victimes
les blessés et est accompagné de
psychologues ne se sont pas encore posé
les corps seront ensuite rapatriés vers
la chapelle ardente et puis les parents
viendront ici où un certain nombre de
leurs proches les attendent ici dans le
collège saint françois d'assise
après l'avalanche meurtrière d or une
information judiciaire sera ouverte en
début de semaine pour rechercher les
responsabilités individuelles et
collectives
nous y reviendrons dans un instant mais
d'abord revoyant le fil des événements
qui a conduit cette classe de 4e sur la
crête du lauzet yannick aroussi
jean-françois giorgetti le drapeau à
damier jaune et noir flotte toujours
pour avertir du risque d'avalanches
c'est d'ici que le groupe est parti hier
matin trente deux adolescents encadrés
par des professionnels de la montagne on
n'arrive pas à comprendre comment des
professionnels de la montagne ont plus
s'engager dans une pente aussi
dangereuses sans faire demi tour je
crois que la première qualité d'un
professionnel de la montagne comme comme
les gens qui encadraient ces jeunes là
c'est de savoir faire demi tour
à partir du moment où il ya un danger
important et là on ne s'explique pas
comment ils ont pu poursuivre dans cette
voie là au départ de la promenade
la pente est douce à travers forêts et
plateau d itinéraire connu jusqu'à la
crête du lowe's et où s'est produit
l'accident où le groupe s'est retrouvé
pris au piège au pied d'une plaque à
vent ce matin malgré l'émotion ressentie
dans la région
quelques promeneurs par compter les
points ce qui montre que le plus
je pensais famille etc et d'envoyer les
enfants à la neige
il faut vraiment les dangers de la
montagne rené roux les côtoie depuis 30
ans les évalue tous les jours ici on se
trouve devant une pente qui peut devenir
l'enchère à tout moment connaissance du
terrain emploi systématique des arv rené
ne se sentent pas à l'abri de l'accident
nous lie de haute montagne
auryn devise c'est quand on part avec un
client ou un compagnon de cordée est
bien l'objectif pour nous c'est de le
ramener et si on ne ramène pas c'est
vrai quelques paris à échec
et puis malheureusement la montagne est
toujours là pour rappeler que c'est elle
qui sait plus forte que nous
rené ne porte pas de jugement sur son
collègue qui conduisait le groupe i hier
bien sûr l'accident est un sérieux coup
au moral mais il notamment rien envie de
faire partager la montagne quelques
heures à peine après le drame les
premiers témoignages semblait mettre en
cause l'imprudence ou la négligence de
la randonnée l'enquète qui est déjà en
cours déterminera les différentes
responsabilités benoît duquesne si
visseyrias que faisait un moniteur
chevronné guide de haute montagne sur
cette crête du lauzet avec 26,2 laissant
derrière lui at il pris un risque
inconsidéré et déclencher cette
avalanche c'est la question que tout le
monde se pose ici à commencer par les
enquêteurs la parution parce qu'elle est
fissurée là encore être vous pouvez nous
dire ce que vous faites un petit peu on
va livrer à des concertations dans une
coupe du monde des jeux et on
regarderait densité est température le
type de grain qu'on a
vous avez ici par exemple sur cette
crête de versant un versant au vent et
un versant sous le vent voyez cette
structure ici vous avez ce qu'on appelle
nous dans le jargon les vagues
vous avez un apport de neige ici par
vendre une compression de neige qui va
donner une énorme quantité comprimé qui
va être posée sur l'ancienne couche et
par effet mécanique les tensions sont
rompues et à ce moment là toute la
plaque et des vis
et tout a glissé en portant du même coup
les randonneurs 11 sont morts comprimé
par d'énormes blocs de neige
écrasés contre les arbres alors pendant
qu on ausculte la neige qu'on l'analyse
content après coup nous ont percé le
mystère
la question revient avec les premiers
éléments de réponses fournies par les
adolescents qui hier se trouver là
moniteur nous c'est une plaque à vent
donc la blanche qu'ont déclenchée dans
mon malheur est bon qu'il fallait faire
très attention à ce que vous étiez au
moment de l'incident situation d' alerte
peut dire que tu as dit que par erreur
vous n'étiez dans un secteur près
d'ancenis on savait que le peloton demi
on n'était pas vraiment créatif on
suivait les traces
je suis tombé de la trace je me suis
retrouvée parce que je me suis retrouvé
l'avalanche voir mais j'étais même pas
du tout brillé chez dg d à dégager vers
la fin des situations mal j'étais sorti
ce matin dans la vallée le guide
accompagnateur s'est donc rendu à la
gendarmerie pour y être entendu comme
témoin et pendant qu'ils répondent aux
questions
tout le monde ici ne parle que de cela
de son attitude de ses aptitudes et de
ses choix
très franchement quand nous sommes en
période d' alerte maximale en termes
d'avalanche comme nous sommes en milieu
de journée à un endroit on sait que la
neige se transforme
on n'y va pas nous y connaît la personne
qui a accompagné un oncle groupe moi
c'est quelqu'un que je connais comme
quelqu'un de sensé compétents et qui a
toujours fait son métier correctement ce
qui est dommage c'est que ce qu'on
puisse emmener des enfants
de base à jda faire n'importe quoi toute
la journée le centre ucpa de châteauroux
les alpes est resté hermétiquement fermé
l'accès est protégé par les gendarmes
personnes officiellement ne veut plus
réagir à quelques kilomètres de là dans
celui des heures une journée de ski sur
piste presque ordinaire vient de se
terminer
qu'est ce que vous vous dites vous entre
moniteur en ce moment là c'est des
choses qui arrivent à tout le monde
c'est pas votre arrivée à un groupe de
jeunes ça peut arriver ça arrivé en
début de saison en résultent sont
arrivés ici ça arrive ça peut pas il
arrivera encore faut-il croire alors que
le danger est inhérent à la montagne que
le risque zéro n'existe pas sans doute
dit on ici et c'est pour cela qu'avec
des enfants
on redouble de prudence venons en au
comportement et à l'équipement des
randonneurs lorsqu'ils partent en haute
montagne
il existe un code et des règles à suivre
parce qu'elle nous c'est bon l'avalanche
est là toujours terrifier les
montagnards surpris les meilleurs
d'entre eux et elle passionne les
chercheurs aux orres c'est une plaque à
vent ou plaques sous le vent qui a
remporté les randonneurs
la neige est soufflé d'une phase de la
montagne à l'autre se forment alors une
corniche et une couche la fameuse plaque
à vent dont la température et la nature
sont différentes de la sous couche
d'où sa tendance à se désolidariser soit
de façon naturelle soit au passage de
skieurs ou de randonneurs les lycéens et
leurs accompagnateurs ont apparemment vu
une plaque au dessus d'eux dans une
pente moyenne
ils ont quand même poursuivi leur route
et selon les premiers éléments de
l'enquète ont déclenché l'avalanche par
leur passage
quitte à s'engager il aurait dû le faire
un par un
cet engin aurait pu leur sauver la vie
l'arva appareil de recherche de victimes
en avalanche ce petit émetteur récepteur
permet aux sauveteurs ou aux rescapés de
retrouver toute personne enfouis on peut
le louer dans la plupart des stations
les lycéens en avait pas d'autre part le
sac de tout randonneur doit contenir au
minimum une pelle à neige une sonde et
une couverture de survie pour pouvoir
chercher est tiré d'affaires ses
compagnons
là encore les lycéens n'avaient rien de
tout ça la fatalité existe mais le
comportement et l'équipement loft
épargner des vies
ils nous rejoignent en direct d or
benoît duquesne vous êtes vous allez à
vos côtés le lieutenant jona de la crs
de briançon apparemment le groupe n'a
pas pris les précautions nécessaires par
risque d'avalanches absolument c'est ce
qu'on va voir dans un instant avec le
lieutenant mais d'abord je voudrais
parler un petit peu du sentiment qu'il y
à ici dans cette vallée est un sentiment
le choc
lorsqu'on est toujours très très choquée
quand la montagne frappe
si on en a l'habitude et surtout quand
elles frappent durement et puis un
sentiment partagé vis-à-vis de l'homme
qu'on désigne aujourd'hui pour le
responsable de cette histoire c'est à
dire le guide pour ce qu'ils connaissent
et bien c'était un homme consciencieux
et compétent et donc on s'explique pas
les fautes qu'il aurait dû commettre
pour d'autres et bien il a un sentiment
partagé de se dire que toujours en
montagne on n'est pas à l'abri d'un
d'une faute d'une imprudence voir et
bien de la fatalité qui vient vous
rattraper et que ce genre d'accident
peut arriver aux meilleurs et puis il ya
quand même les faits on vient de voir il
parce qu'elle joue c'est bon à savoir
deux choses que n'avait pas fait
l'accompagnateur avec avec c'est les
gens qui l'accompagnaient les jeunes
alors dieu tu envoies savoir un petit
peu quand on voit mis bout à bout toutes
les je dirais pas les erreurs mais en
tout cas ces manquements qu'il y avait
aux règles c est ce que est ce que cet
accompagnateur a été sérieux dans son
travail ce guide je pense que
comme vous l'avez comme vous venez de le
dire leur en montagne le risque zéro
n'existe pas toutefois on peut on peut
se prémunir en fait d'un certain nombre
de risques et tout au moins d'en limiter
les conséquences et je pense
particulièrement à cet appareil de
recherche de victimes en avalanche dont
apparemment aucune personne de ce groupe
n'était muni ça va me arva dont on a
parlé un instant tout à fait je pense
que si si chacun en avait des porteurs
on aurait pu réduire considérablement
les délais d'intervention et de
localisation des victimes et s'engager
sur une voie comme celle-là je même au
début c'est un chemin de ski de fond qui
est balisé sur lequel on indique je
croyais à des panneaux qui indiquent
qu'il ya risque d'avalanches
tout à fait mais là il était en fait
sortis de cette piste de ski de fond et
il progressait en direction d'une crête
et est-ce qu'un guide peut s'engager
comme ça avec un groupe aussi important
alors qu'il y à des risques aussi
conséquent d'avalanche tout à fait c'est
possible mais sous réserve de prendre
certaines précautions de progression
entre autres c'est à dire c'est ce passé
suffisamment pour que qu'en cas de
déventer d'avalanche l'enchantent d'une
groupe ne faut pas ensevelis d'après les
premiers éléments les premières
constatations de la passion c'est
effectivement le groupe qui lui-même a
déclenché l'avalanche dont il a une
débilité a fait à l'heure actuelle on
peut maintenant affirmer de façon
certaine que c'est le sait le groupe par
son passage à un point précis de cette
crête qui était l'élément déclencheur de
cette avalanche si vous pensez que le
guide a fait une erreur dans cette
histoire ça je pense que je laisserai le
soin aux juges de rechercher les
éventuelles responsabilités alors savons
s'adresse bien sûr le travail du juge
pour l'instant on est dans une enquête
ce qu'on appelle une enquête
préliminaire c'est le procureur qui
dirige la gendarmerie dans cette enquête
il ya eu des auditions pas seulement du
guide aujourd'hui mais aussi d'autres
personnes qui se trouvaient dans cette
expédition
et puis c'est l'audition bien
continueront demain il y aura vous
l'avez dit lundi l'ouverture d'une
information judiciaire
merci benoît duquesne et voilà ce que
l'on pouvait dire ce soir sur ce drame
qui ne peut que nous toucher à cuba des
centaines de milliers de personnes pour
assister à la messe célébrée par le pape
jean paul ii retransmise en direct par
la télévision d'état
le saint père en a profité pour lancer
un appel à la reconnaissance des droits
de l'homme philippe gassot
la visite du saint père à santiago de
cuba la deuxième ville du pays est
marqué par des signes d'une extrême
fatigue
et c'est peut-être cela qui fait la
puissance de ce vieil homme qui brûlent
visiblement ses dernières forces pour
rassembler les hommes et faire passer
son message de plaies sur le parcours le
saint père a dû se reposer à plusieurs
reprises tout au long du voyage à cuba
l'église a évoqué le retour à la lumière
le saint père est venu se recueillir
devant la vierge de la charité du cuivre
qui est pour tout le peuple cubain
croyants ou non la sainte patronne de
lille fidel castro après hemingway est
venue lui rendre hommage dans le passé
il ya bien longtemps après 30 années
dans l'ombre elle sort de son sanctuaire
celle qui réunit tous les cubains permet
au pape d'évoquer l'avenir c'est aussi
l'église par don de la paix et la
réconciliation
pendant que saint père est à santiago de
cuba on est un peu déçu ici à la havane
on s'attendait en effet à une réponse du
gouvernement cubain
à propos des demandes de grâce présentée
par le vatican et qui conserve des
prisonniers de droit commun et aussi
quelques prisonniers politiques jusqu'à
présent le gouvernement garde le silence
aux etats unis le scandale qui touche la
maison blanche se resserre autour d'un
témoin clé la jeune monica levinsky
ancien stagiaire est présumée maîtresse
du président aujourd'hui on apprend que
la jeune femme en échange de sa
coopération réclame une immunité
judiciaire et toute la presse recherche
des images de mener qu'à pour mieux
raconter ses secrets d'alcôve une
correspondance de maryse burgot
voici donc les premières vidéos de celle
qui a semé la panique à la maison
blanche monica lewinsky filmé ici lors
d'une fête de fin d'année à l'école
elle avait alors 14 ans cette jeune
femme en robe rose prétend donc
aujourd'hui avoir eu une liaison avec
une tonne elle dit aussi que le
président lui aurait demandé de lier
cette relation sous serment
l'om ce que la jeune femme réclame
aujourd'hui l'immunité en échange de sa
coopération avec la justice
en clair elle évite la prison si elle
dit la vérité mais selon son avocat elle
ne serait finalement plus prête à dire
que le président a fait pression sur
elle il faut avouer que l'on se perd un
peu dans toute cette histoire
les américains aussi qu'ils ne
comprennent plus leur président il ya
d'abord le visage du président lui-même
voyait jackson clint il fait ce qu'il
dit il le fait bien
l'économie est bonne le pays se sent
bien et puis ya là des cultes il ne dit
pas ce qu'il fait il ne le dis pas parce
que ça n'est pas bien
le temps passe et les révélations se
succèdent
selon certaines sources des objets
offerts par clinton à levinsky auraient
été saisis dans son appartement dont une
robe tachée du sperme du président en
moins d'une semaine la cote de
popularité de bill clinton a chuté de 10
points alors à la maison blanche les
conseillers cherche la stratégie à
adopter face au public américain hier il
était question que bill clinton
s'adresse à la télévision finalement les
avocats lui aurait conseillé de ne pas
parler avant mardi jour de l'important
discours devant le congrès les attentats
en algérie se multiplient à quelques
jours de la fin du ramadan au moins cinq
bombe aurait explosé hier notamment dans
la capitale et à blida 23 civils
auraient été tués dans ces actes
meurtriers et puis en chine 89 criminels
ont été exécutés à pékin avant le nouvel
an chinois des exécutions collectives
qui selon les autorités sont destinés à
assurer la tranquillité des habitants
jacques chirac au premier jour de sa
visite
d'état en inde vante les mérites de la
france et de ses patrons accompagné par
le ministre de l'économie et le
président du cnpf le chef de l'état veut
faire en sorte que la france devienne un
partenaire économique majeur de l'inde
reportage véronique sainte olive jean
cornu où la france l'opération est
importante
le président de la république avec une
trentaine de responsables industriels
parmi ceux qui comptent le plus est venu
essayer de créer des liens avec l'inde
ils partent de zéro aujourd'hui la
france n'est que le dix huitième
fournisseur et le 13e client de la plus
grande démocratie du monde
cinquante ans après son indépendance
loeb est désormais ouverte sur
l'extérieur 300 millions d'indiens
vivent encore sous le seuil de la
pauvreté
mais malgré des pesanteurs de normes
l'inde entame une modernisation qui fera
d'elle bientôt l'une des plus grandes
puissances économiques du monde
dans ce contexte bombay est aujourd'hui
une plaque tournante du business
international
ainsi pendant que le couple de la
république vante à ses hôtes le savoir
faire français
quelques salons plus loin c'est cindy
crawford qui s'emploie à la promotion
d'articles de luxe et devant un parterre
de grands décideurs indien jacques
chirac lui se pose plus que jamais
envers et de la france parce que trop de
nos compatriotes demeurent sans emploi
parce que le monde bouge et se
transforme la france comme les autres
pays doivent s'adapter
je suis comptable de la bonne insertion
de mon pays dans l'économie mondiale
mondiale et mondialisée pôle emploi pour
nos entreprises pour garantir notre
place et notre courant dans le monde
avec vos chefs d'entreprise prestigieux
et quelques ministres aussi assez pop et
le président de la république veut être
celui qui dynamise l'ouverture de
nouveaux marchés et de nouvelles
relations politiques pour la france
c'est une sorte de répartition des pages
pendant que le gouvernement se débat
dans les urgences
jacques chirac lui s'efforce d'engranger
voit l'avenir avec le mouvement des
chômeurs la cote de popularité de lionel
jospin plonge pour la première fois
depuis son arrivée à matignon selon
l'ifop journal du dimanche il perd 9
points avec 42 % de satisfaits contre
46,2 mécontents sa chute ne profite pas
particulièrement au président de la
république qui perd trois points avec
45% d'opinions favorables contre 41 de
mécontents
coup d'envoi dans la région provence
alpes côte d'azur de la campagne pour
les régionales une région hautement
stratégique convoité par jean marie le
pen ses adversaires dont françois
léotard et michel vauzelle ont réuni
leurs troupes et michaël darmon philippe
dix milles et jean marie le pen au
dessus de la région provence alpes côte
d'azur le président du front national
qui n'aime pas trop les campagnes de
proximité choisi l'hélicoptère pour se
lancer dans la compétition régionale
une fois revenu sur terre les choses
sont moins faciles pour lui à menton les
opposants au fn latentes sur son
parcours
casquette et par cas le chef du parti
d'extrême droite candidat à la
présidence de la région développe son
discours habituel contre l'immigration
j'ai regardé la frontière bon il passe
des cures c'est la mode des kurdes
d'ailleurs la dot y aura les deux pans
de la dèche qui aura les pakistanais y
aura les chinois les ados mais les
autres têtes d'affiché étaient également
de sortie à toulon les militants udf
l'attendait depuis longtemps
il est revenu nouvelle permanence
nouvelle union rpr udf et nouveaux défis
qu françois léotard avec toujours le
poids du fn au centre du débat régional
nous inaugurerons mes chers amis cette
permanence pour exprimer notre volonté
de reconquérir à toulon comme dans toute
la provence pied à pied
quartier par quartier ville par ville
les terrains qui ont été conquis dans
les esprits par le front national
au même moment à marseille de socialiste
michel vauzelle présenté lui aussi sa
liste et son plan de bataille changer
l'avenir c'est de dire écarter la menace
que fait peser le front national avec
des solutions de violence et de haine
c'est tourner la page d'une gestion de
droite qui a été très insuffisant michel
vauzelle françois léotard et jean marie
le pen
trois candidats à la présidence d'une
région stratégique pour la campagne
commence plus tôt le parti communiste a
décidé de jouer la transparence sur son
histoire en organisant aujourd'hui une
journée portes ouvertes à disposition
les archives du pc de l'avant-guerre à
1968 un geste symbolique pour répondre à
la polémique de ces derniers mois sur le
nombre de victimes ont fait les régimes
communistes dans le monde
reste que cette journée vérité les
sceptiques à un grand nombre
d'historiens olivier caroff dominique
bonnet
mais nos amis du passé faisons table
rase tous les communistes connaissent le
slogan mais pour robert hue séquence
nostalgie aujourd'hui avec une
exposition des plus belles affiches du
parti communiste de la libération années
60 une certaine vision du monde où tout
paraît simple des certitudes des dogmes
une soumission totale à moscou le
meilleur moyen de prouver que désormais
tout a changé
ça montre aux françaises et aux français
notre volonté farouche de regarder avec
la plus grande lucidité ce qu'ont été
les évolutions intérieur de votre parti
pour mieux aujourd'hui poursuivre sa
mutation c'est un seul un effort
exceptionnel dans l'annoncé de sa
mutation
une mutation qui laisse sceptique
certains historiens venus débattre place
du colonel fabien de la délicate
question des archives le pcf promet de
les rendre plus facile d'accès mais
seulement pour les documents de plus de
30 ans et encore pas pour tous ce qu'ils
ont absolument pas abordée c'est tout ce
qui est en relation le clown soviétique
n'existe pas et cet historien c'est
qu'une partie de ces documents se trouve
à quelques mètres sous ses pieds une
cave où dorment des milliers de pages
retraçant la politique extérieure du pcf
officiellement l'inventaire aura bientôt
lieu
mais certains savent déjà où trouver la
mémoire du communisme français
elle est dans les archives du komintern
dans la salle commune ou du kominform
elle est dans le fond staline avant elle
est dans le fond lénine est toujours
dans les archives du komintern et dans
les archives du du parti bolchévique et
elle est aussi dans les archives du nkvd
guépéou kgb le kgb dont les entrailles
pourrait notamment receler ce qu'on
appelait au pcf des biographies en fait
des fiches où les cadres du parti
devaient tous confié de leur vie
jusqu'aux opinions politiques de leurs
enfants
j'en viens à cette extraordinaire
histoire médicale au monde seuls deux ou
trois femmes ont vécu cette anomalie
scientifique à tour d'une même grossesse
sont nés le même jour deux filles d'âge
différent je m'explique
cette femme de 40 ans est tombée
enceinte une deuxième fois
trois semaines après avoir démarré une
première grossesse reportage exclusif
jean daniel flaysakier va sans doute
piguet sociale et lucilia sont nés le
même jour de la même mère et du même
père officiellement elles sont donc
jumelles et pourtant médicalement elles
ne le sont absolument pas aussi
incroyable que cela puisse paraître ses
deux enfants n'ont pas le même âge
l'embryon dos yann s'est développé trois
semaines après celui de lui s'il ya un
cas presque unique au monde l'accoucheur
ans nie d'ailleurs encore tout ému selon
les connaissances classique
effectivement c'est tout à fait aberrant
de penser que deux envoyons puisse avoir
trois semaines la différence car on ne
voit pas comment ça peut se faire selon
les données classiques mais là vous êtes
sûr que c'est pourtant bien le cas
et là c'est pourtant certainement moins
élevé j'ai dit que ce n'était pas
possible
et maintenant je suis brouiller les
différences s'effacent il comprend oui
c'est plus facile et elle c'est lucie
lie à la grande 3 kg 2 né après 38
semaines de grossesse gauche la petite
c'est océane nés après seulement 35
semaines nous prématurité dont témoigne
la jonas qui colore sabres 2 le plus
surprenant dans cette aventure c'est que
grâce à l'échographie les médecins ont
pu semaine après semaine suivre le
déroulement de ses deux grossesses ici
par exemple le diamètre du crâne de lui
s'il ya fait le double de celui de sa
soeur et quelques semaines plus tard
pendant que la petite océane et sur le
dos sa grande soeur se prélassent elle
sur le ventre les s'il ya beaucoup plus
tôt ni alors que là elle est moins
tonique à la haye les yéyés vaut bien il
reste une question importante chantal
déjà mère de quatre enfants
houle et un fils c'est raté alors
va-t-elle persévérer croire fort à un an
en saône-et-loire plus de cent mille
visiteurs attendus ce week-end pour la
traditionnelle fête de la saint vincent
la grande cette bourguignonne de la vie
et du vagin espère un pas de saint
vincent tournante digne de ce nom sans
le casse-croûte bourguignon pour
accueillir les vignerons de toute la
région bruit n'a pas failli à la
tradition
au programme un très gros sandwich et un
petit coup de blanc du rugby évidemment
merci
alors sciemment l'effort le réconfort
c'est par après mais la saint-vincent
n'est pas qu'une histoire d'estomac
c'est avant tout la fête des sociétés de
secours mutuels créés au 19e siècle bien
avant la naissance de la sécu pour les
vignes ans et c'est toute cette entraide
qui se passe dans l'est dans les
villages quand un vigneron au 17
atteindront une maladie peu parce
qu'elles sont trop graves donc c'est
cette entraide entre nous et on veut un
peu le lui donner une dimension beaucoup
plus grande alors musique en tête
baigneurs souvent le saint vincent
communal bien calés sur l'épaule les
vignerons de bobl défilent au petit
matin au pas de charge
comme s'il était pressé d'en finir
quelques heures concédait la tradition
juste avant que ruine accueille ses
visiteurs ses clients pourrait-on dire
cent mille attendu pendant le week-end
la règle est simple il suffit d'acheter
son verre 30 francs et de le faire
remplir autant de fois que l'on veut
autant de fois que l'on peut se battre
un peu on s'est battu on a eu c'est
inabordable annule pas trouve pas un
caveau
légèrement grisé saint vincent a préféré
quitter les lieux et laisser la place à
bacchus à mulhouse
retour triomphal de notre nouvelle
championne du monde de natation accueil
chaleureux à l'aéroport deux à trois
cents personnes pour fêter roxana
maracineanu de retour d'australie la
jeune française de 22 ans était attendu
par sa famille par les nageurs du
mulhouse olympique natation et par ses
amis de la faculté des fleurs mais aussi
du pain du sel et du vin où selon la
tradition roumaine puisque roxana est né
en roumanie
tennis avec la performance des français
aux internationaux d'australie
quatre d'entre eux sont toujours en lice
ils font partie des 16 joueurs
sélectionnés françois brabant à
melbourne cette semaine c'est peu de
dire que les français ont la rage
pour nicolas escudé et son petit poing
dressé c'est une nouveauté pour mary
pierce et sethi tape sur les cuisses
c'est une bonne habitude qui revient
nicolas escudé c'est un éternel espoir
qui a décidé cette année de devenir un
espoir tout court face à rennes et
bergues l'américain qui a un nom suédois
et qui joue comme un suédois
le petit français a beaucoup couru
beaucoup et longtemps mais il l'a passée
mené deux manches à rien il s'est
accroché pour remporter les trois autres
et gagner à melbourne son deuxième match
en cinq sets de la semaine comme lionel
ruth guillaume raoux juste avant lui il
s'est payé le droit de lever la main
vainqueur à la sortie
marie-pierre elle melbourne elle connaît
elle a gagné il ya trois ans elle était
en finale l'an passé
c'est sans doute pour ça que cette année
elle passe tous ses tours sans trembler
victoire en deux sets contre olga
paravent chico va y a pas de quoi
s'énerver
enfin pas de quoi pour nous français
mais pour les australiens se purge
australienne cette journée ça a été
comme un cauchemar éveillé
la faute à lui alberto berasategui
vainqueur en quatre sets de patrick
rafter numéro deux mondial et idole de
tout le pays cette défaite c'est comme
si le ciel leur est tombé sur la tête
nous français on n'a pas fini de se
sentir léger cette nuit c'est à sandrine
testud et cédric que vivent deux jours
nous rejoignons maintenant patricia kaas
en direct de valence bonsoir vous venez
de commencer une tournée qui s'achèvera
à la fin de l'année mais tout de suite
pour votre retour sur scène place à
votre talent en écoute
m
une ville mythique pour décor des
auteurs compositeurs tels que jean
jacques goldman
le tout pour servir sa voix le retour de
patricia kaas s'annonce à la hauteur de
ses dernières apparitions tout
simplement comme un événement
patricia kaas dix ans de carrière des
millions d'albums vendus et votre retour
sur scène pour une tournée qui devrait
passer par bercy vous êtes ce soir à
valence comment se sont faits les
retrouvailles avec le public très bien
parce que en fait c'est une façon
différente de défendre ses chansons et
ça c'est assez longtemps que j'attendais
parce que j'aime le contact avec le
public alors au début c'est toujours un
peu marrant parce que les premiers soirs
les rideau ne tombe pas au moment où il
faut alors il faut improviser puis le
public apprécie parce qu'ils ont
vraiment l'impression de faire partie de
deux du spectacle de la préparation du
spectacle
on a comparé votre réussite à celle d'un
boxeur milieu modeste dureté de la vie
ait envie de conquérir le monde
ça me ressemble au j'irai peut-être pas
jusque là mais j'aime partager ma
passion et puis si on peut appeler ça se
battre bain en tout cas c'est avec
beaucoup de plaisir et puis les coups ne
font pas très mal que reste-t-il de la
chanteuse de forbach fille de lorraine
qui chantait dans les bassins houillers
en bas il reste beaucoup de choses il
reste juste que effectivement le temps
passe et puis on change un peu en charge
physiquement changeant sa tête on n'a
plus confiance parce qu'on apprend la
vie vous apprend mais sinon les émotions
les sont toujours les mêmes et j'aime
j'aime beaucoup parler d'eux de mon
enfance parce que parce que c'est là que
j'ai tout appris
c'est important d'avoir faire à votre
famille l'image de votre succès de wii
c'est important de le partager avec eux
parce qu'ils m'ont toujours soutenu et
pour moi la famille c'est vraiment très
important est de savoir qui sont là qui
pensent à moi qui mets mais voilà donc
bien sûr le succès c'est pour moi avons
trouve mais j'aime le partager avec ceux
qui m'aiment patricia kaas en france on
un peu l'amanite que les des étiquettes
tour à tour vous avez été la nouvelle
piaf la madone à française l'héritière
de marlène dietrich d'ailleurs vous en
avez un peu joué est ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous vous sentez différente et peut être
plus libre
tant que tant que ce sont des étiquettes
d'artistes que j'aime je les apprécie
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui j'ai
envie d'être moi même et je pense que
quand on vient voir le spectacle on
comprends pas ce que j'ai vraiment voulu
exprimer dans ce spectacle mais
différentes facettes et effectivement il
ya un petit peu plus des moments
d'émotion mais aussi des moments
d'énergie et mais en tout cas les les
étiquettes ça va c'est pas ça ne gêne
pas trop mais j'ai quand même envie
d'être moi on a le sentiment que vous
n'avez plus rien à prouver
ce n'est qu'une apparence il ya toujours
encore de la fragilité avec peut-être la
peur de ne plus surprendre au on a
toujours à prouver jamais à prouver
parce que le plus important c'est déjà
de se faire plaisir ensuite savoir qui
est un public qui vous suivent c'est ce
qui est plus beau et c'est ce que je
peux voir tous les jours en ce moment
parce que le plus beau cadeau pour un
artiste c'est quand le public se déplace
et vient de voir à ton spectacle
donc après on a des rêves on a des
envies et puis bon ben on avance et puis
mais bon on n'a pas envie de surprendre
on a envie de donner plus merci merci
patricia kaas d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
merci beaucoup le salon international de
la lingerie a ouvert ses portes hier une
manifestation qui est devenue un rendez
vous incontournable qu'on suivait pour
nous nicolas cornu langlois et bernard
connor
elles ont raison de le claironner haut
et fort la lingerie française se porte
bien en deuxième position sur le marché
mondial
une augmentation annuelle de 2 8% du
chiffre d'affaires et un constat la
femme lui consacre 20 % de ses dépenses
d'habillement pis éloge de la
transparence avec la ligne nuage de
l'ogec une lingerie insoupçonnable mais
efficace sous le pull moulant le
soutien-gorge s'ouvre devant le charme à
fleur de peau avec les actuels de 8 un
moule et sans couture qui maintient
galbe sans exagérer pour tricher il faut
le prochain en mousse et silicone
bonne tenue de la lingerie couture comme
nina ricci jeu délicat des couleurs
dentelle de calais et pour les
nostalgiques le style saloon la guêpière
corsetée de marilyn monroe dans la
rivière sans retour
les ombres des de sandra maritimes
peuvent se porter en bustier sous une
veste
enfin l inverse de cette lingerie
flamboyante agressive voici le confort
et la rigueur du sport avec calcul les
ados adorent pour l luxure ne doit pas
rimer avec torture elle préfère la lure
nature et le top model christy
turlington en est le porte parole
prestigieux challenge raid une part
nécessaire de notre lieu elle doit nous
rendre jolie mais elle doit surtout être
confortable l'érotisme se porte en soi à
l'intérieur et la lingerie doit l'aider
cette lingerie santé beauté sécurité se
retrouvent dans cette chorégraphie de
dim
le bien-être pour les femmes sonore est
il le glas des fantasmes pour les hommes
la jarretière tricolore de germes pour
dior sous la combine est où d'autres
valeurs sûres résiste pour les rêves
érotiques 1
ainsi se termine ce journal je vous en
rappelle les principaux titres le
cortège emmenant les victimes et les
enfants rescapé de l'avalanche
meurtrière devrait regagner la région
parisienne dans la soirée le chagrin et
la dignité des femmes il enquête sur les
responsabilités devrait déterminer s'il
y avait véritablement imprudence
l'avalanche aurait été déclenchée par le
passage des randonneurs aux états unis
le scandale qui touche la maison blanche
se resserre autour d'un témoin clé la
jeune monica levinsky ancien stagiaire
est présumée maîtresse du président
aujourd'hui on apprend que la jeune
femme en échange de sa coopération
réclame l'immunité judiciaire
dans un instant la météo isabelle
martinez des températures froides à
20h55 fait la fête michel drucker demain
7h dans thé ou café catherine ceylac que
reçoit evelyne bouix pierre arditi pour
le mari la femme et l'allemand j'aurai
le plaisir de vous retrouver demain soir
à 20h merci pour votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2
ce soir